I don't think you realize how crazy
Saudi Arabia's propaganda room is 40 of
all tweets from the Arab world come from
Saudi Arabia much of which comes from
this single room using this online Army
Saudi Arabia's Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman or MBs is able to push whatever
story he wants to the absolute top
hashtag vision2030 trending hashtag
Riyad Rising trending hashtag MBS rocks
trending not only does this room push
certain narratives to the top but it
also pushes opposing narratives to the
bottom if you have any sort of relevance
within the Arab world and you post
something that's not in the Saudi
family's best interest well then the
Army is gonna flood your post with the
negative comments and the dislikes we
may even see these trolls under this
video at first Twitter tried to take
down this Army by deleting thousands of
their fake Accounts at one point they
had even deleted as many as 88 000
but eventually even Twitter gave up the
problem is that these tweets aren't
coming from Bots we're talking about
hundreds of real people working full
time on this effort making it extremely
difficult to discern between and ever
since Elon bought Twitter all hopes of
this Army being taken down have been
completely crushed you see Elon didn't
buy out of Twitter single-handedly he
had several investors pitch in and his
biggest investor was none other than
Saudi Prince Paul will lead with no one
else willing to fight against this
propaganda the Saudi people have taken
this matter into their own hands through
a movement called the B movement the
idea is pretty simple just do the exact
same thing that Saudi Arabia is doing
but with the might of the Saudi
population
surely a few hundred trolls have no
chance against the country of millions
right well in theory yes but Saudi
Arabia isn't exactly putting up a fair
fight the founder of the movement at
Jamal khashoggi has literally been
assassinated and the country has been
arresting leaders of the B movement left
and right so join me as we explore Saudi
Arabia's quest to extend their
dictatorship into the online world
taking a look back via online space in
Saudi Arabia wasn't always so animated
in fact the Saudi people didn't even get
internet till 1999 because the kingdom
was concerned about exactly this online
protests the spread of dissenting ideas
and a more powerful societal voice but
by 2000 the internet was getting so big
that continuing to ignore it would
simply leave the country behind
so Saudi Arabia would go ahead and
Implement a very limited version of the
internet Saudi internet was to be
regulated by the King abdulaziz City for
Science and Technology or kcsd kacst was
responsible for monitoring all internet
traffic coming into the country and
ensuring that Saudi values and beliefs
were protected to be honest it's not
clear how effective this organization
was and actually regulating internet
traffic but its mere existence itself
was enough to deter people from doing
anything SAS after all you didn't want
to see what was on the other side of
being caught so people primarily just
use the internet for research and
educational purposes as opposed to
social media or entertainment this made
the kingdom rather closed off even
though they were technically connected
to the internet but that wasn't a
problem in fact that's exactly what the
kingdom wanted they didn't care about
Western perception or influencing the
global narrow as long as the oil
business was booming and they had the
Saudi people in line that's all they
cared about but all of this would change
on January 4th
2010. this day marked a Monumental day
for their neighbors the UAE as this was
the grand opening of the Burj Khalifa
first glance it was just another vanity
Tower but Dubai had a grand plans for
this building Dubai was going to use
this pointy structure to gain worldwide
relevance through social media travel
Airlines and even movies I mean who
could forget that famous scene where Tom
Cruise kills the side of the Burj
Khalifa and Mission Impossible this was
by no means Dubai's first PR stunt they
had been trying to ship Global
perception for decades but the reality
was that Dubai was a broke bomb they
were one of the only Middle Eastern
cities that didn't have oil so they were
trying to build a tourist Hub which
wasn't working out all that great in
fact they literally went bankrupt trying
to build the Burj Khalifa and Abu Dhabi
had to bail them out but fortunately for
Dubai the Burj Khalifa garnered more
attention than they could have ever
dreamed of suddenly everyone knew about
the Palm Islands the Burj Al Arab
Atlantis the palm and the lavish malls
the Lamborghini police and of course
Emirates and their a380s almost
overnight Dubai's outlandish dreams of
becoming a tourist Paradise became a
reality
and all of their fake fortunes became
real fortunes Saudi Arabia didn't really
care about Dubai's fortunes as Dubai's
world was still peanuts in comparison to
Saudi wealth but what did cats saw his
attention was Dubai's oil Independence
less than one percent of Dubai's GDP was
coming from oil meanwhile nearly half of
Saudi Arabia's GDP was coming from oil
clearly it was time for something to
change
[Music]
well all of this was unfolding and Bs
was barely 24 years old but he already
had the years of the country's most
powerful leaders
several roles as a special advisor and a
personal aide and to him the future of
Saudi Arabia was clear he had to free
Saudi Arabia from oil he was going to
westernize the country Latin tourists
for the first time and revolutionized
Western perception
but before he did all that he would be
met with a harsh reminder of just what
he was up against between 2010 and 2012
the Middle East would be rocked by a
series of uprisings called the Arab
Spring essentially a bunch of
authoritarian Middle Eastern countries
would see massive protests regarding
human rights violations corruption and
wealth inequality the protest started in
Tunisia but they would quickly spread to
Libya Egypt Yemen Syria and the Bahrain
and do you know what was Central to all
of this the internet the usage of social
media doubled amongst these countries
throughout the Arab Spring social media
was how activists were able to
communicate organize and retaliate in
fact 9 out of 10 Egyptians and tunisians
admitted that they were using Facebook
to organize protests and spread
awareness the scariest part for these
dictators was that all of this was
actually working in early 2011 tunisia's
president of 23 years Ben Ali would run
away to Saudi Arabia meanwhile in Yemen
the president would newly be
assassinated before he too would run
away to Saudi Arabia and see the power
this quickly became a trend as the
leaders of Egypt and Libya would also
end up resigning the Middle East was in
turmoil and many of its leaders were
turning to Saudi Arabia for help and
Saudi Arabia would indeed step in in
March of 2011 Saudi Arabia and the UAE
would send forces to Buck rain to occupy
the country and silence the protests but
the UAE and Saudi Arabia weren't able to
be the saviors for long as protests are
erupting in their own countries these
guys didn't mess around though they had
already seen in several of their peers
get overthrown by similar uprisings so
they would put their foot down almost
immediately the UAE would go out and
arrest 94 of the most influential
journalists lawyers teachers and student
activists and throw them in a secret
prison some of these individuals are
still in prison to this day meanwhile
Saudi Arabia's military would squash
protests using Brute Force things were
looking worse than ever throughout much
of the Middle East infrastructure had
been demolished Supply chains had been
disrupted inflation was out of control
and poverty was reaching up record highs
and in the end it was these internal
forces that would finally put an end to
the Arab Spring
as it became harder and harder to just
get by people slowly lost the ability to
fight even if they still had the will to
fight and pretty soon the Arab Spring
would turn into the Arab winter
Saudi Arabia had come out Victorious but
MBS had seen firsthand just how
dangerous the internet could be to
authoritative regimes and let's just say
MBS kept this in mind when he became the
Crown Prince in 2017.
MBS was set on westernizing the country
he had this massive Plan called division
2030 That was supposed to free Saudi
Arabia of its oil dependence and
honestly it's actually a pretty fine
plan he was going to invest their oil
wells into health education
infrastructure Recreation and tourism
but this of course came with a caveat he
wanted to revolutionize Saudi Arabia
without seating power and to make sure
that he didn't lose control he was going
to build up an online Army to enforce
his rule but before he could do all this
he had to First raise money Vision 2030
entailed spending hundreds of billions
every single year so he needed some
pretty deep pockets and who better to
get this from than saudi's own Elite in
late 2017 MBS would round off the
country's 400 most powerful people in a
Ritz Carlton Hotel and he would turn the
hotel into a jail he basically told lead
that they could leave as soon as they
admitted that they were quote unquote
corrupt and paid up were these people
actually corrupt probably did MBS
actually care about their corruption
though probably not this was simply a
masterful way to not only raise money
but show the kingdom who was really in
control and let's just say he raised a
lot of money over 100 billion dollars to
be precise this means that MBS milked a
cool quarter billion from each person
not a bad day's work but that was just
phase one phase two of his fundraising
effort consisted of taking their
National Oil Company Saudi aramco public
in the world's largest IPO with a
valuation of two trillion dollars by
this point MBS had a country's wealth
and leaders under control The Next Step
was keeping the country's people in line
despite the new freedoms enter the
Twitter Army as we touched on in the
intro MBS would straight up create an
entire Twitter battle station with these
sole intent of promoting his agenda
across social media and given how much
Manpower he's dedicated to his effort
it's not surprising that it was quite
effective everything that was trending
on Arab Twitter was exactly what MBS
wanted to Trend Number One Vision 2030
number two Riyadh Rising number three
MBS rocks number six Vision 2030 number
7 Crown Prince shout out to the ace
family they were literally able to
outperform state-sponsored propaganda
anyway the Saudi people would start
referring to the state Army as the Flies
and from that we would see a new
movement pop up called the bees the bees
would do the exact same thing as the
Flies but instead of pushing
state-sponsored propaganda the bees
would push for social awareness and
political reform the first viral hashtag
from the bees was what do you know about
the bees initially posted by the
movement's founder Jamal khoshogi but
just a few weeks after this post went
viral Jamal khashoggi would be be
assassinated the Saudis probably thought
that this would have finally put an end
to this movement but it simply made it
far stronger as it guarded International
attention and sympathy this did lead to
Saudi Arabia backing down for a little
as they laid low avoiding the spotlight
but there's still a long road ahead as
in the end the Saudi people are directly
fighting against a state-sponsored
propaganda machine backed by one of the
wealthiest countries on Earth all that
wealth may not last for long though in
fact there's Insider evidence that Saudi
Arabia may very well be lying about
their oil reserves if you want to learn
more check out this video but until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one
foreign